[Music]  possibly resisting the fact that you saw  I am celibate because I don't give up I  got a new commendable job thou should  not let you just sit on the beach  [Music]  they're monsters don't fight and you can  fight me I'll be standing right here and  my tiny bulls are white thank you look  John Thain go home that South Carolina  black bee got to pause they say your  father was a great man  you must be what's left need to stop  hating known games teach you how to  dress would that be unbelievable no one  in your family ever lives to see us  and it rhyme against the dark side of  the horse why even bother so many dudes  been with your mom only the nose upon  your father  [Music]